Hello Freak bitches.
So there's a lot of people still clinging onto the old,
you know how things you like,
like you said,
people need to watch a show at a certain time or listen to the radio,
like drive time.
Right.
What the fuck?
Who listens to radio on the fucking drive and the will,
the first thing that switched it up with Sirius Xm,
cause when serious,
when it was at Sam,
you know,
and a opie and Anthony were on and Howard stern is on what they figured out when
they were doing this or it's like,
look,
we don't have to have any censorship.
We could say whatever the fuck we want.
But they started getting in trouble too.
Like opie and Anthony got banned off the air wants because they brought in a
homeless guy and he started talking about banging Condoleezza Rice.
Oh yeah,
I did open think they were cool.
I didn't one of them,
but it's not opening Anthony now.
Topian Jimmy Anthony,
he's got his own thing now.
He's got a radio.
But I remember it was funny too,
because I think you're right about that.
Sirius Xm was one a big thing.
Cause I remember when hat Owen's stern who I used to listen to,
who by the way,
I listen,
let's do later because Kentucky,
my hometown didn't have started going on,
but I started listening to them and I loved him and said,
he's going to sell that radio.
We can say wherever he wants.
And they're like,
well,
he's not going to be as funny.
Half the fun is listen to him trying to talk around and then you listen and you
go,
that's such a fucking hoe.
It's so much fucking fun here when he's not.
He's just saying it.
That idea that it's,
it's more fun to be censored when people proof theory's wrong.
You know that's a dump theory though.
That's like,
didn't you hear that all the time?
I heard that all the fucking time.
I never heard that.
I see here that about comedy,
but I was always like whatever.
Sam Kinison and Richard Pryor,
my all time favorites.
Like how the fuck can you tell me who's funnier?
And Richard Pryor,
I mean it was funny.
The Richard Pryor and how can you tell me that beating around the Bush would be
better than what prior was doing?
You can't,
you can't say you have to be quiet and maybe it was more in the south,
but I kept hearing,
you know,
now that he's not got like the FCC to fight against and he can,
the fun was him trying to get around the census and he really listened to it and
you go,
it's so much fucking better now that you know,
that's bullshit just to be free.
Completely free to express yourself without any worry about a word that's going
to get you fine for hundreds of thousands of dollars.
And you gotta remember like he got,
he got sued by the FCC,
right?
Like healed making the task.
He had to go to court over that shit and they wound up finding him like ungodly
amounts of money and there was nobody out there with him when he was doing that.
Like he's this,
one of the reasons why I'll never criticize that guy.
He's like,
he's like one of the most important pioneers when it comes to radio.
Like if it wasn't for that guy and going out there like that and getting sued
and and having,
that was all during the fucking Bush administration man when they were those
John and Jack fucking time.
Yeah,
those John Ashcroft fucks man.
That guy was scary though.
All these people that were trying,
there was,
there was a lot of religious shit behind it.
That'd be shit.
Their shit in their boots over this fucking record too.
Well they would be dying over that record but he got sued.
I mean he,
he actually had to spend real money and real stress.
Imagine the government trying to take you out all you are as a dirty morning
radio guy and the fucking government is trying take you out.
You fucking probably get paranoid as shit.
You should get paranoid.
You fucking should be paranoid.
What does it say here Jamie?
There all the different fines he had to pay for 1999
he paid them.
Yeah,
some of them got paid.
This isn't probably the initial finds that they started as either,
but I think this is what they got whittled down to,
or let's read them off.
That'll 1990 he got fined $6,000 from the FCC.
1992 we got fined $105,000 from the FCC.
1992 again,
he got fined.
600,000 1993 got five find 500,000 1993 got fined.
Seventy three thousand thirty seven thousand four hundred thousand in 94 200,094
holy fuck.
And then it just keeps going on and on.
And on.
The last one right there,
495,000 in 2004 2000 and fucking four and that fucking insane.
That's during the Bush administration.
After nine 11 he got fined $1 million.
$95,000 half a million dollars in fines for saying bad words.
Wasn't even saying bad words.
He didn't even say bad words.
He didn't swear.
That's what was crazy.
Just top it subject matter.
The d like talking about farts or Piss or shit or something like that.
It was so crazy though.
Such a crazy time.
If I were to say that to someone who didn't know,
they would think,
oh you mean that the 50s or the 40 this is fucking 2000 thousand four and if he
didn't go through that,
if there wasn't this backlash from the public finding out about it,
cause everybody I know that heard about it was like what?
How would they wasting our fucking money suing him over a radio show that by the
way has 20 million people listening to it every morning.
It's pretty obvious that people were enjoying this radio show and when they stop
enjoying it it'll go off the air.
That's what the fucking free market is about.
But it wasn't about that.
What it was about is controlling somewhat cause it wasn't just his dirty shit.
That's not what concerned them as much as his,
his criticism of the Bush administration,
his criticism,
political political policies and his willingness to say whatever the fuck he
wants.
He's a dangerous guy.
He said too much power.
You think him?
You think that's what Kinda started podcasts.
Do you think that?
No,
I don't think that's what started podcasts.
Um,
but I think that for him that started the,
the,
the journey eventually to Xm,
like he had to,
to serious whatever it was at the time.
He had to like,
they were fucking with him constantly all the time.
I don't think he gets enough credit for that.
It's insanity man.
Yeah.
Well he's,
I,
he loses,
he said he's a hero of mine that in 2040 got fine for those that cock for spink
during a product for maintaining anal and genital hygiene.
Thompson was going after him.
He was doing those things after video games and stuff too.
If you're from the Tennessee guy,
he got Davis and attorney Jack Thompson supplied.
The FCC was show transcripts.
Oh God.
And listen,
I don't need,
that's not what I,
I pay my fucking,
well nobody did,
but it wasn't official.
I guarantee you a lot of it was about controlling a powerful guy cause he had
talked about running for governor member,
remember?
Yeah.
But he would have got to have to disclose how much money he made and that's when
he decided not to do it.
I wonder if you would do that now because now everybody knows he's got a
hundreds of millions of dollars.
I wonder if it even the people run now.
They haven't disclosed shit.
Well,
Trump has.
Trump says he's worth more than he actually is.
That's what's hilarious about him.
I know,
but I'm saying has he,
have we seen the actual like,
well,
Bernie Sanders just released his tax returns in his tax turn.
Said that he made less money last year than Hillary Clinton did for one single
speech.
Holy.
He made $200,000 and she's made as much as I think to 90 for once be maybe even
in the threes for one speech.
I want to ask you to negotiate.
I'll,
I'll release my own fucking return.
They're like of money.
I lost.
How many seats is this?
Is about 400 seats.
Okay.
I want end up like,
you know,
quarter million bucks.
What did I just told you?
There's like 400 seats.
Like,
how much are we charging these people and we're going to pay you that to 25.
I think memory,
I'll take that pearl jam,
fighting over ticket prices,
making sure they don't get to be 25 bucks and now when people are paying
250,000,
I know.
Watch a speech.
Well that is uh,
obviously just bribery money.
It's just bizarre that she won't release the transcripts of the bribery money
teachers.
Anytime you don't want to release something,
it's always good.
Imagine what she said.
You know,
it probably sacrificing babies and shit and lighten owls on fire.
We probably had an effigy and the war was probably all over them papers
probably.
He was probably one of the reasons why she kept her mouth shut.
If it keeps,
it keeps his album's coming out,
I'm all for it.
Yeah.
Whatever he's gotta do,
man.
There's a lot of people that need to be shot,
right?
Well,
yeah,
no,
no.
He's not taking out the good guy he's taking,
he's taking out enemies of the state.
That's what's up,
dude.
He's like a showtime,
um,
drama series,
assassin type guy.
Maybe it'll make that show.
Imagine if that was the show.
Sturgill Simpson just run around there.
It was like,
do you remember that movie where the guy from the gong show chuck.
Oh,
come check the writings of a dangerous mind.
Yeah,
that was cool.
It was kind of crazy.
I was half out of it and watching that movie in a hotel room in Vegas and I know
I remember like falling asleep from memory.
It was a cry,
but he wasn't really worried.
He thought he was worried for the gun that was,
but it was really weird.
It was like,
what is this like?
I remember reading it like reading a passage from it too,
like it's a book and I remember reading the passage going,
what is this?
Is this fake?
Was he on drugs?
Like what is this?
I never got into it.
We were talking you speaking of that Shit,
talking about,
you know,
First Amendment,
freedom fighters,
one of the,
he a major hero and people don't know about it from Kentucky Zone.
Mr Larry Flynt,
he did a lot of fun.
I don't think people realize how I'm putting it.
There was that movie made out,
but I don't think,
and he's um,
and people you get laughed at when you say Larry Flint,
Flint is a hero of yours.
Cause he's like,
oh,
cause you love hustler.
And you know,
I love Nikki,
but it's not what I'm talking about.
No,
no freedom speech.
Matt,
he did more for freedom of speech than probably anyone alive right now that you
had to be as fucking crazy as he took that shit to the supreme court because he
was fucking insane and he's rich as fuck.
And he didn't get,
yeah,
the was the perfect amount.
It was a perfect timing to these.
This is before porn hit the internet and the money kind of eroded.
Yeah.
You know,
back then he was selling those magazines.
He was rich from selling magazine.
He was going to lose everything because of a fucking Joe when I was,
yeah,
he really was.
When I first came to la,
I remember seeing that building,
that flip publications building.
Oh yeah.
The norm is fucking huge.
I knew some of the,
the his,
I don't know.
I've,
I've met him briefly.
I know some of the hit,
you know,
family members back in Kentucky.
But yeah they got,
they um,
it's an empire but also I think when he dies it'll come up.
It'll be talking about it,
you know,
they'll be,
they'll be the joke,
he national news shit,
but there'll be some really interesting fucking pieces written about what he
actually did cause he really changed everything.
And like this album,
literally I couldn't make this album without lyrics.
I agree.
And I think that what was going on with him at the same time as what was going
on with a Howard Stern,
there were all real similar.
I was real similar and the government was trying to decide what people could and
couldn't do and the people that didn't get defended where the dirty ones tell
dirty magazine guy,
the dirty radio guy,
for whatever reason we didn't,
they didn't get defended.
Where a journalist,
if a journalist is getting attacked like that for revealing the truth about
something,
people would be up in arms,
the intellectuals be up in arms.
But nobody recognized that.
It's just as dangerous to tell people that they can't jerk off to hustler as it
is to tell like a political dissident that that's they said at the trial.
I mean the Ed Norton Guy Played Him.
He's like,
this has nothing to do with whether you like hustler and has to,
it's no different than any free speech trial anywhere.
But by the way,
if you,
you know,
if you rule against this,
that it could lead to people being censored in all,
in all different forms.
But this is,
it took something that fall that crazy to get it to the supreme court and
someone that fucking crazy.
It's just too problematic when you,
when you tell people what they can and can't talk about,
it's too problematic.
You know,
if you,
if you censor someone for a specialty,
like sexual stuff,
like you sensor someone for putting out a magazine where people have sex and it,
you know,
obviously people have liked that forever.
You do know what the,
what the actual trial was.
Uh,
I'll,
I'll repeat it if it was an obscenity trial.
Right.
But he,
he did it.
He actually,
they had comic pieces in the magazine and he did a piece where he said that this
one,
I may need help,
but Jerry,
Jerry Falwell,
I think men,
but men find it online.
But you said that before I find out it was,
I want to get the guy's name right before I fucking Jerry Falwell,
Larry Flint.
Um,
he was the big guy at the time,
right.
Jerry Falwell's guy that got caught with a hooker to wasn't it or has Jimmy
Swaggart I get them all mixed up.
Jimmy Swaggart cried on TV.
It was awesome.
You don't remember that?
Oh yeah,
I saw that.
Yeah,
man.
I used to,
I used to watch that shit all the time.
It was amazing.
It was amazing because we all knew that he was a crazy fuck.
We need,
it's not cherry fall.
It's a Larry Flynt and,
uh,
just Google Larry Flynt Supreme Court.
Anyway,
the point was this preacher had sex with his mom and an outhouse.
Outhouse.
Yeah.
In the magazine.
And I've made like,
we had a cartoon of it,
right.
And I went and saw Larry Flynt speak cause I said,
like I said,
I'm a big fan of his and so they,
the guy sued them.
Well it's Jerry Falwell.
Okay.
That's what I thought.
So he said Jerry Falwell had sex with his mom and an outhouse and it was a
cartoon,
like a mad magazine for part two.
And your follow suit them for liable,
you know,
not,
he's like,
it's obviously a fucking joke.
Like I'm,
I don't think you know,
this is fucking comedy.
And he sued them and it went to the fucking supreme court.
And I went and saw the Larry Flynt talk and when they repeat,
when the lawyer,
this is Larry Flynt said this is what,
when he knew,
he knew he was going to win the supreme court trial.
When his lawyer repeated what the article said that his,
his mom had sex at.
Jerry Falwell had sex,
his Momma House,
he saw the supreme,
he saw the judges giggle for a second and the lawyer stopped and he's like,
and that's when he knew he had the trial one because the whole point is,
you laughed when I said it,
that this guy fucking his mom out in and out house.
Obviously it's how are we going to have an argument that's not comedy when all
all you fuckers just started laughing.
He said from that point on he knew he was going to win.
And it was funny too,
he also said that Jerry Falwell came to him years later and they became friends
and he wanted to go do a speak cause I guess he had,
you know,
maybe not watch his money.
He wanted to go do a speaking tour with Larry Flynt.
And uh,
it's like,
what thought I just,
you know,
I want the biggest supreme court freedom of speech he's ever again,
he said he realized that's when they kind of,
he's like Jerry Falwell too.
It's all a show.
You know,
it's all,
it was just a,
it was just theater to him.
Like,
we,
we can go out and make some money on the road and we talk about each other.
Exactly.
The friends like fuck you.
That was,
I was,
I was serious about it.
And um,
we had a funny though,
it was like the party with Jerry Falwell find out what it goes down,
but when he got drunk he did become friends.
And another one I'd have to look,
I,
I'm almost positive that when he died,
Larry Flynt wrote his maybe for the La Times.
I think Larry Flynt wrote his obituary.
Really?
You know.
Wow.
But yeah,
they became friendly or later,
but it was,
it's an interesting trial.
You should definitely check out.
Um,
and the movie is sums it up,
but you got to get into the details of it because what they used to do at hustle
was pretty fucking crazy.
I mean,
besides,
you know,
really getting in there,
looking inside the post and all that shit.
They're like,
they had been in shit,
like they would do crazy like kind of x rated mad magazine and that was a chip.
Ironically,
they've got him in trouble like,
you know,
as you know that the,
it was what it was the the second year that they were actually pissed about.
But yeah,
but that was what they could catch him on because there were so preposterous.
Some of them are so graphic.
That was,
I guess.
Yeah,
that must've been the one that was the guy who,
uh,
this is the letter he wrote in the La Times after he died.
How I find myself,
it is,
he is a phrase that's his,
that's Larry Flynt Obituary for the article is called the porn king and the
preacher.
Interesting.
Is there the 1997 autobiography or biography called an unseemly man.
Yeah,
he's hilarious.
Let's look.
He sued him for $50 million.
That's why I went to the Supreme Court.
He kept losing the case.
I lost repeatedly yet eventually won a supreme court.
Wow.
I kept losing it.
Now he's hugging me in front of millions on the Larry King show.
Whoa.
That's the same one.
How much it cost him to fight those off because someone suing you for $50
million.
If he lost her repeatedly,
each one of those things that's it had,
luckily it was the right guy who was crazy enough,
like you said,
and had the money to fight it because most people would have just never wouldn't
have thought at once much less.
All the way up to the supreme court.
Yeah.
It's funny,
man.
It's funny.
The whole thing is funny.
Yeah.
I mean the real story.
It's one of those things where the real stories crazier in the fucking mood.
Well it's,
it's crazy that it's such a pivotal moment in free speech history yet.
Like you said,
it's not something anybody ever talks about that he actually had to go out
there.
Like,
I mean they were saying before there's an SNL might not exist if that was,
if he had won that case.
Well,
look,
if he can a daily show or any of that shit.
If you can't,
if you can't parody public figures,
SNL can happen,
right?
You can't do the daily show,
you know?
And we could prove that.
And here's the way to prove it.
It's sort of a round about way,
but marijuana is still illegal in 2016 because of some bullshit propaganda that
was made in the 1930s so that momentum carries on,
even though it doesn't make any sense.
You could still go to jail today for growing pot.
So if you think that if Howard stern didn't have those lawsuits,
didn't pay all that money,
didn't make this big public outright did public outcry,
didn't have to go to Sirius satellite radio.
If all those things didn't happen and they won,
what if they shut him down?
What if they pulled him off the air with Larry Larry Flynt loss and never fought
it would have everything buckled down.
How long would it take for the Internet to happen?
How would it,
what would have taken forward?
Things like reddit or four Chan or these fucking uncensored blogs or uncensored
youtube content where you can do whatever you want.
Vimeo,
all that shit podcast,
that ripple from those two guys is like one of the most important ripples for
free speech media in 2016 and it's one of most important,
like pivotal moments in the history of free speech,
and we're talking about that.
It's amazing,
right?
It's fucking crazy and crazy that we're talking about an x ray had record that I
own on a podcast that you own.
Yeah.
This wouldn't have been fucking like this whole world.
The whole thing wouldn't have happened.
Okay.